there is Cleveland 23 and 9 by virtue of
the loss there's a corner three and it's
good my demar derozan Valentinus finds
DeRozan and Tamar connects and he's
filed God
Philadelphia played on Tuesday they lost
to Sacramento here's Tamar the prey and
it's good to gobble it up bring it into
the frontcourt and attack McConnell a
kick-out here's DeRozan the three and he
got it
and DeMar DeRozan has made four threes
Simmons up fake no place to go Lowry
gets it back to devotion
DeRozan between the legs rises up and
the J is good he's got 17 having a nice
game here six points six rebounds four
assists
Raptors can tighten up this defense over
the last 2:30 of the second quarter see
if they can get something easy here
Simmons always chasing after DeRozan
DeRozan and with another first half with
20-plus points he has 22 and oh keep
this in mind and they lost by 6
corrosion and we've seen the rapper's
rappers get behind and their team that
don't panic
Sarris makes his way over to the table
near SERDES finds DeLong DeRozan the 3
god and DeMar DeRozan ties his career
best the lights the tie his shoe double
mine DeRozan from downtown and he is 6
of 7 from three-point range 3rd Raptors
down by 4
[Applause]
DeRozan on the inside this soft roll
Lowry DeRozan hurdle baka and POW on the
floor shot doesn't go DeRozan putback 34
4 point games and up top gotta make
shots here shots down the stretch
DeRozan 37 he was just too cool